I was born in 66 this movie came out in
67 I grew up with these characters and
what was nice for me is that Alan you
know he grew up with the book so we both
had different perspectives on something
that we both cared deeply about and as
we all sat and talked about it and
developed it finding the balance between
the iconic mythic power of the Kipling
and all of the images that I loved
growing up with from from the animated
feature it was it was how do you combine
those things and most importantly how do
you use today's technology to take it to
a different place than the film that
already exists how do you build upon
that legacy but but I figured it's d23
we got to come down here and maybe even
bring some cast members for you to see
figured out great artists let's do that
so we got a few I'd like to introduce
playing Bagheera Ben Kingsley we also
have Lupita Nyong'o who plays Raksha and
finally our discovery first movie
playing Mowgli Neel Sethi he'll give
them a warm d23 welcome
may I start by saying that when I was
Neal's age I probably heard for the
first time when you wish upon a star and
something inside me popped with a kind
of recognition and it's been a long
journey but thanks John and thanks
Disney for helping little boy's dream
come true I'm now part of that which
moved me as a child so much and it's
great to make a contribution to the
wonderful world of Disney that we all
love and inhabit first of all I just
want to say this is my first time at
Disneyland so I grew up my mom had a
dream board think she wanted to achieve
and accomplish for her family and one of
them was to bring us to Disneyland she
didn't necessarily bring me here so I'm
here for her
thank you and here's our first look at
how
you
you